quante cose cambiano in dieci anni e va
beh lo sapete come ogni anno arriva
l'inverno e porta con sé i regali il
panettone il grasso sotto anche le
unghie dei piedi e soprattutto una
povertà ma c'è una tradizione che nella
mia famiglia non è mai passata di moda
che l'azzardo di natale allora io
proporrei tipo piccionaia di un tabù che
ne dite
a natale si gioca si gioca assalti che
facciamo 31 cucco bestia sette e mezzo
voglio giocare a poker
no dai non ma che poi inizia la bisca ci
spendiamo cioè finiamo sotto i ponti
riuscì giocarti la vita vie di mezzo no
no non sono più un bambino ragazzi io
voglio giocare las vegas
io voglio venderlo e mi madre è bravo
nei bot è l'unico vero neo cresciuto un
guaglione come a te se un tempo i grandi
volevano far vincere i piccoli a tutti i
costi adesso sono i piccoli che vogliono
spennare chiunque cioè fino all'anno
prima mangiavano le loro stesse felici
adesso la merda la pronuncia rate quelli
lì non giocano colpo con le poste da un
euro quelli mettono i libretti d'assegni
davanti mettono le buste di droga tipo
narcos coppia
ho usato perché in tutto questo mica
sono sfigati no lo diceva pure pitagora
il quadrato costruito sulla giovinezza
di una persona è inversamente
proporzionale alla circonferenza e il
suo bucio de culo a natale a casa né si
scommette su qualsiasi cosa chi vuole
banche europee di madre
ciao ragazzi un pò di capire cosa mi
hanno regalato 40 roma io non ho i
ragazzi buonanotte mi metto a dormire
subito che sono stanco morto
se sempre un lay terremo specchio
giocare
a casa mia fa proprio male allo spirito
delle feste
ogni volta che a casa mia ci si siede
attorno a un tavolo da gioco una fatina
muore e tutti quegli ideali tipo quanto
è bello stare insieme il pensiero che
conta bisogna dare per ricevere cazzate
da me vogliono i soldi sono disposti a
fare qualsiasi cosa se tv un mio parente
si avvicina ai nipoti con con la busta
carina quei soldi dentro quello lì
rischia di perdere la mano mentre la da
su questa busta c'è scritto davide chi è
la fanno le leggi il biglietto 50 euro
meglio il cazzo ci faccio 50 euro che
c'è scritto io questi me il gioco io con
questi non li raddoppio mi faccio dice
compra droga capito già perché se fino a
dieci anni fa a cerete punteggio massimo
da poter spendere al gioco all'interno
della nostra famiglia adesso le cose
sono leggermente cambiate adesso il
bronx in e parenti pur di comprare non
lo so una carta del mercante in fiera
che tra parentesi gran gioco di merda
possiamo dirlo pur di comprarsi una
carta loro sono disposti veramente a
darti le chiavi della macchina oppure da
un etto di midollo osseo perfetto
mercante in fiera questo è un buon mazzo
partiamo da 5 mia ora c'è stato è stato
breve in contanti prezzi
beni per il birdie per il bene non sono
storia questo sci monitore di una
meredith a prendere di l'altra in via
adesso prende resto scimunito altrimenti
ti faccio il cellulare e domani sotto
osceno momento al figlio police car
pavimento una lingua poi scarpa i
rituali domar traguardo è pure il cobol
pulitura del pavimento 1 pulitura del
parola gamba prende anche un pò della
nonna buona gamba dalla nonna dal
normale mia vita va vissuta biglia tende
a rendere il clima natalizio più leggero
e ci si mette le regole del morto che
metterebbe in crisi
l'amore di una madre per il proprio
figlio o quello che corona per le truffe
per chi non lo sapesse la regola del
morto consiste in questo presente nei
giochi apposte quando una persona perde
tutte quante le sue monetine davanti
automaticamente perde tutte le sue vite
e quindi muore questo cosa comporta che
i vivi non possono e non debbono
assolutamente parlare con i morti perché
qualora un vivo dovesse parlare con
morto a quel punto dovrebbe dargli una
delle sue poste da un euro o il bancomat
come il caso la mia famiglia è una
regola molto semplice se parli col morto
il morto torna in vita a discapito tuo
ok un banale no ecco quando muore
qualcuno all'interno della mia famiglia
succede il delirio scendono ragazzi sono
morto
e morto guglielmo è moreno fino al 2019
ma vacci tu io pronto miei bellante
oddio impazzisco per questo euro
minchione ecco cosa c'è un minchione
marco vuole o non fare tutto a posto
tutto a posto la barocco è morto il
migliore la cosa veramente bella però
del natale in famiglia da me così giusto
per chiudere a questo breve pensiero è
che a un certo punto finisce ci sono
persone ci sono parenti che dopo la
vigilia non sono più le stesse persone
che vivono esperienze così
traumatizzanti che alla fine delle feste
sono veramente costrette ad abbandonare
il lavoro e chiudersi in rehab fino a
pasqua ma questa storia di dolore vi
assicuro che ha una morale che sotto
sotto se se scavi bene con una trivella
ha effettivamente un messaggio positivo
perché esattamente dieci anni fa
caricavo il mio primo video su youtube
che aveva lo stesso titolo e parlava
fondamentalmente della dello stesso tema
per questo video e ho pensato a fare
degli eventi a creare un qualcosa di
colossale affare veramente le cose in
grande però alla fine ho pensato di
optare forse per una cosa semplice anche
perché alla fine dieci anni fa un
piccolo gesto veramente cambiato in
maniera enorme la mia vita è anche
perché se come fondamentalmente con i
tempi stretti il mal quale è veramente
la morale di tutto questo è che vedono
la vita a volte può essere una merda può
essere difficile ma finché ci resterà la
possibilità di di ridere e di trovare un
modo per sorridere in quelle che sono le
nostre piccole o grandi difficoltà
allora troveremo sempre un modo per
andare avanti e quando ci renderemo
veramente conto che le cose complesse
realtà sono fatte da tante cose semplici
e che per giungere un traguardo in
realtà bisogna iniziare mettendo un
piede dopo l'altro allora forse
veramente vivremo molto più sereni in
dieci anni non ce l'ho fatta io chiudo
questo video in questo modo era un
piccolo omaggio a quello che è stata
veramente una giornata che che mi ha
cambiato e stravolto completamente la
vide a davide
che insieme tra vita e video che dire
ragazzi io vi auguro un buon anno anzi
ci auguro un buon i dieci anni ciao ciao
l'anno prossimo